hey this is presh talwalkar
what is the correct answer to the
following expression
this math problem has gone viral
generating millions of comments on
facebook twitter youtube and other
social media sites
in this video i'm going to present the
correct answer
we can solve for the correct answer
using the order of operations
these are commonly remembered as pemdas
or bodmas and these are a precedence of
how we evaluate operations
this will be parentheses brackets
exponents orders multiplication division
and addition subtraction
furthermore if you have operations of
the same precedence you should evaluate
them from left to right
the first part of this expression has no
controversy
there's a parenthetical expression that
needs to get evaluated first
we have nine plus three in parentheses
so we evaluate 9 plus 3 to get 12.
now there's a question of what to do
next
if you input this expression into any
scientific calculator you will see that
it will interpret this two parentheses
12 as an implicit multiplication
so we need to convert this parentheses
into an implicit multiplication of two
times twelve
we now continue with the order of
operations
we have a division and a multiplication
as we have operations of the same
precedence we should evaluate them from
left to right
so we take 48 divided by 2 and that gets
us to 24
and now we have a final expression of a
multiplication which is 24 times 12 and
that is equal to the correct answer of
288
this is without a doubt the correct
answer to this expression according to
the modern interpretation of the order
of operations
so why is there so much controversy
about this problem
well let's return to the expression
it turns out the order of operations did
historically have an exception
i found a math paper in 1917 that noted
a special exception using the division
symbol
this may have been used in school for
many more years and some of you may have
even learned under this rule
so when we go under this interpretation
we still start out the same way we have
a parenthetical expression nine plus
three and we evaluate that first
so this becomes twelve
the question is what to do next
so historically there was some usage
that if you use this division symbol you
would divide everything on the left by
everything on the right
textbooks may have written x divided by
2y to mean x divided by the quantity 2y
as you can see in terms of typesetting
it would have been much easier to write
x division symbol 2y
rather than writing the slash and then
parentheses around the 2y
you would end up writing a lot of
slashes and a lot of parentheses it
wouldn't be very easy to read and so it
would have been much more convenient to
write x division symbol 2y and just
everyone would understand that 2y is
grouped together
so if you were to use this historical
interpretation
how would we evaluate our expression
using this special rule we have
something on the left which is 48 and
something on the right which is two
parentheses 12.
so if we group the terms on the left and
the right
we then have 48 over 2 times 12
we now simplify the denominator which
has a multiplication
2 times 12 will be equal to 24
and then we finish out 48 divided by 24
which is equal to two
so this would have been considered the
correct answer historically
using the kind of inline type setting of
the division symbol
nowadays we don't use this
and you can see that calculators don't
evaluate the expression this way
so the correct answer under the modern
interpretation is
288
did you get that answer
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and puzzles you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description